SCP-682, the indestructible reptile, versus
SCP-3519, a dangerous memetic contagion
responsible for killing nearly the entire
population of the world. In a certain timeline,
SCP-3519 infected global media to influence the
public into believing that the world would end on
March 5th, 2019, and that self-destruction was a
preferable option. Weeks before March 5th, a group
of Foundation personnel decided
to test 3519’s exposure with 682,
in hopes that it may terminate the lizard once and
for all. Lowering the acid levels inside its tank,
682 was exposed to the contagion, but did not
show any self-destructive ideation. Instead,
682 nightmarishly laughed for 193 seconds
before it was placed back into containment.
After March 5th, there was
only one lone human survivor,
Junior Researcher Dr. Rory Jones. When
682 encountered the Doctor after breaching
containment, it did not kill him.
Instead, it simply stated:
“We are alike now, meat. Killing
you would only end suffering.”